was geht hier vor max und ich sitze vor
mein pc und ich spiele heute nichts weiß
schon relativ spät ist und ich wollte
eigentlich gt-r aufnehmen aber es hat
nicht geklappt und deshalb das einfach
mal zum anlass so ein bisschen zu
trocken lagern ist das was los und zwar
habt ihr gemerkt kommt manchmal so nur
alle zwei tage videos und so und wie ich
auch schon bei einem anderen video
gesagt hat ist es irgendwie so dass ich
mich nur noch wenig begeistern kann
die vp aufzunehmen ich spiele auch gerne
habe ich nicht gerne auf weil ich mir
denke dass jetzt so viele videos online
und irgendwie musste mal dass cooles
machen nur weil ich das noch nicht so
wirklich gefunden was ich gerne machen
möchte ich wollte eigentlich gern mal
apps und sowas aufnehmen
damit man nicht so irgendwie intensiv
beschäftigt wie man das macht was für
coole apps es gibt und ich war da schon
von browsergames aufnehmen aber da finde
ich auch nie irgendwelche cool
also wenn ihr irgendwas gutes habt dann
könnt ihr das gerne schicken
irgendwie komisch dieses video zu machen
wir eigentlich ist ja meine aufgabe
coole dinge zu finden aber werde ich
auch und ich freue mich schon darauf zb
die blocks vom auftritt mit lukas
veröffentlichen
da geht es los am 21 september am 21
september geht's los und ich glaube das
ist montag einfach mehr montag um 18.30
kommen die ersten blogs online
die werden auf jeden fall cool und was
sich sonst noch groß sagen
einfach so in meinen gedanken also ich
weiß nicht so krass was sich hochladen
wie soll ich wollte einfach heute so gta
5 aufnehmen wie ich einfach sechs
sternen
kriege und einfach so ein bisschen dabei
quatschen
hättet ihr bock das vielleicht zu sehen
oder sonst irgendwelche anregungen auf
jeden fall mal sehen was ich so mache
die welt wahrscheinlich genauso sehen
die ich glaube schon wieder kacke und
jetzt haben wir eine ganze menge zu tun
weil für mich geht ja auch die schule
wieder los und hat auch sonst vieles zu
tun
und das werde ich jetzt alles machen auf
jeden fall ich werde mich strukturieren
freunde und dann kommen coole videos und
regelmäßig und nicht nur mal so mal so
ja sag ich jetzt und ich hoffe ich hatte
ist ein okay danach fünf besten teams